Good morning, John. It's Thursday, March 8th.
I'm walking downtown to try and find some people to give peeps to. There are technically a lot of people around
but they're all in cars. I'm having a hard time getting them to notice me.
Free peeps!
Free, free peep-, free, no, I'm not stopping. It's kind of snowing and cold.
I kind of hate you a lot.
Starting to be a lot more people around.
This is the kind of town I live in.
My general opinion is that it's going to be quite difficult to get rid of these peeps.There are a lot less people downtown than I thought there would be.
I usually only go downtown at night,
so I kind of assumed that it would just be a bunch of college students,
who are kind of mostly drunk.
But it's not drunk college students. It's business people and soccer moms on errands.
They don't look like they want peeps.
Also, I don't know how I'm going to film them because people usually aren't okay with that kind of thing.
I think I'm gonna have to hide the camera.
This looks like a pretty good place to hide a camera.
Want one? Free peeps.
Man: Can't even give those things away, huh?
It's very difficult.
You might want to take some peeps home. They're free.
Hi, do you like peeps?
Hi.
She ran away from me.
Okay, I just got a bunch.
[Singing to himself]
This isn't working.
Okay, this looks promising. There's a bunch of punk rockers down the street.
But it's going to be hard to record them.
So I'm just going to turn the camera on and leave it in my pocket-- you *hear* what happens.
Hey guys.
I have a ridiculous number of peeps.
(Man 1): I would love some peeps.
I mean, I have like a hundred of them.
(Man 1): Oh damn, don't competitively eat amongst yourselves.
[Laughter]
(Man 1): Definitely.
I've been trying to give them away all day. People are like [high-pitched] "there's a crazy guy trying to give me peeps"
[More laughter]
(Man 1): Nice
You don't have to take all of them, but I would appreciate it if you did.
(Man 1): We're going to.
I'm Hank, by the way.
(Man: 1) I'm Kurt. (Hank): Hey Kurt.
(Man 2): I'm Brad. (Hank): Hey. (Brad): Nice to meet you.
(Man:) Machine Gun. (Hank): Hey, Machine Gun. (Machine Gun): Nice to meet you.
That's, uh, twelve peeps in your hand right now.
(Kurt): Yep, twelve peeps.
I do not want you to choke yourself.
(Man): No, y'know, he does this for a living. A freakshow. Just watch. Just watch.
(Man): Focus. (Hank): Seriously, people die eating peeps all the time.
We should be timing you.
(Brad): One more man. Put it in there.
It's amazing how much your dog doesn't care about peeps.
How you feeling?
(Kurt): That's a lot of peeps. I feel like I have the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man like fighting the Ghostbusters in my stomach.
Okay
See you guys.
(Man): Definitely.
Thank you very much.
Those guys are probably the most worthy recipients of peeps I have ever seen.
So I went back and timed him and it took him one and a half minutes to do what it took me six minutes to do.
However, I actually felt really,
really,
nauseous at the end of it.
And I hope Kurt is okay because that was a lot of peeps really fast.
Anyway, I have to keep this under 4 minutes, so I'll see you tomorrow.